merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des finances monsieur le
rapporteur spécial
chers collègues
nous examinons à présent les crédits de
la mission aide publique au
développement
avant qu'avec le président Jean-Claude
Riquier nous entrions dans le détail de
la mission je souhaite rappeler que les
crédits demandés environ 8 milliards
d'euros en autorisation d'engagement et
5,9 milliards d'euros en crédit de
paiement ne représente qu'une partie de
l'aide publique au développement
en 1922 en 2022 la France se situe ainsi
au cinquième rang des pays donateurs
après les États-Unis l'Allemagne le
Japon et le Royaume-Uni et le montant
global de l'aide qui s'élève à 13,1
milliard d'euros représente
0,51% du revenu national brut ce qu'on
appelle le RnB
promets-moi la loi de programmation du 4
août 2021 relative au développement
solidaire et à la lutte contre les
inégalités mondiales fixe l'objectif à
atteindre à 0,7% du revenu national brut
il nous faudra sans doute revoir cet
objectif devenu trop ambitieux au regard
des contraintes qui pèsent sur nos
finances publiques en effet pour
atteindre à tel niveau accroître l'aide
publique au développement de 10
milliards d'euros ceux qui semblent
beaucoup trop élevés je note d'ailleurs
que le gouvernement semble avoir
lui-même revisé cet objectif comme il
s'en est ouvert auprès de nos collègues
de la commission des affaires étrangères
madame la ministre
en ce qui concerne les pays
bénéficiaires République au
développement de la France est
principalement tourné vers l'Afrique
j'en profite pour indiquer que désormais
la France s'engage à plus de crédit
d'engage plus de crédit comptabilisés
comme de l'aide publique au
développement en Chine comme c'était
encore le cas il y a peu de temps de
plus si la Turquie perçoit 41,4 millions
d'euros il s'agit de crédits versés pour
financer le mécanisme d'accueil des
réfugiés syriens
comme vous le savez le principal
opérateur de l'aide publique au
développement en France et l'Agence
française de développement l'AFD le
portefeuille d'activité correspond à un
montant d'environ 12 milliards d'euros
cette opérateur ne perçoit pas de
subvention de fonctionnement de la part
de l'État mais des crédits qui
compensent à la fois la parc
concessionnelle des prêts accordés et
les subventions versées sans
contrepartie
l'AFD c'est tutelle négocie en ce moment
le prochain contrat d'objectif et de
moyens le com dont l'un des buts
principaux sera de resserrer le nombre
des indicateurs de suivi afin de rendre
le pilotage plus stratégique cette idée
nous semble intéressant
par ailleurs notre rapport présente pour
la première fois quelques développements
concernant l'aide engagée par les
collectivités territoriales si elle
reste encore modeste avec un montant
d'environ 145 millions d'euros cette
aide est en progression depuis 2018
mon collègue Jean-Claude Riquier qui va
me suivre à ses tribune dire à quelques
mots pour présenter plus précisément les
crédits des programmes qui composent
cette mission ainsi que du compte du
concours financier prêt à des États
étrangers
toutefois je souhaite vous rappeler
qu'au nom de la commission des finances
nous partons devant vous un amendement
visant à réduire de 200 millions d'euros
les crédits de la mission aide publique
au développement nous préciserons
davantage aux bancs notre intention mais
je souhaite dire ici que notre objectif
est d'assurer la participation de la
mission à la maîtrise des comptes
publics
l'aide publique au développement est
certes une politique de puissance mais
elle est avant tout une politique de
solidarité dont la philosophie est
d'ailleurs d'être désintéressé comme la
dit de l'indique le fait que la au
sens de l'OCDE ne peut être lié à
l'obtention de faveur de la part des
États que nous aidons
le contexte budgétaire qui est le nôtre
nous oblige à priori prioriser nos
efforts afin de privilégier nos
concitoyens et nos intérêts en tant que
puissance
pour cette raison si nous devons
préserver les moyens de la sécurité de
la défense de la diplomatie de la santé
et de l'éducation nous devons en tirer
les conséquences sur l'ampleur de la
politique de solidarité que nous menons
à l'égard du reste du monde
sous réserve de l'adoption de
l'amendement de la commission et
éclairée de la présentation des crédits
que s'apprête à vous à vous faire le
président Jean-Claude Reiki je vous
inviterai à adopter les crédits de la
mission APD et ceux du compte de
concours financier très à des États
étrangers merci chers collègues la
parole est maintenant au président
Jean-Claude Roquier rapporteur spécial
de la commission des finances pour 5
minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président mélanise mes chers
collègues combien d'indiquer mon
collègue le sénateur Michel calvette les
crises de la mission aide publique au
développement s'élève à 8 milliards
d'euros à l'autorisation d'engagement et
à 5 milliards 900 millions d'euros en
cueilli de paiement en 2023 les crémiers
les crédits augmentent ainsi très
fortement en effet l'autorisation
d'engagement connaissent une hausse de 1
milliard 400 millions d'euros et les
clés de préventes de plus de 819
millions d'euros le programme de 109
solidarité en ayant des pays en
développement qui relève du ministère de
la faire étrangères concentre les
hausses les plus importantes ainsi le
montant des crédit demandés augmente 837
millions d'euros en automation
d’engagement et 383 millions d'euros en
cri de paiement afin notamment de
renforcer les capacités de gestion de
crise et soutenir les politiques de
santé au niveau mondial comme cela a
déjà été le cas en 2022
augmentent de 336 millions
336 millions d'euros en autation
d'engagement et en raison de la
mobilisation de 256 millions 700000
d'euros pour la reconstitution du fond
mondial de lutte contre le sida la
tuberculose et le paludisme est du
financement consacré à l'alliance GAVI à
hauteur de
94,7 millions d'euros par ailleurs la
création de mécanismes de réserve pour
les crises majeures explique une hausse
de 270 millions d'euros de crédits
demandés sur ce programme c'est
enveloppe rien à compléter 560 millions
d'euros en automation d’engagement et
crédit de paiement déjà dédiés aux
opération de digestion et de sortie de
crise
la création de mécanismes de réserve
pour cette crise majeure paraît bien
venue puisque permettra de donner aux
responsables des programmes des marges
de manœuvres pour financer des
dispositifs d'urgence sans mettre en
cause le financement d'opérations déjà
engagée toutefois nous interrogeons sur
les garanties que seront qui se
rapporter par le gouvernement afin que
ces crédits ne constituent pas une
réserve de budgétisation par temps calme
et qui donne bien lieu à des annulations
ou à des rapports en fin de gestion en
outre nous estimons que le montant
demandé relativement élevé compte tenu
des autres crédit disponibles pour faire
face à l'urgence pour cette raison et
afin de financer les mesures d'économie
demandées à la mission l'avènement de la
condition des finances que nous
présenterons tout à l'heure propose
10.000 100 millions d'euros les crédits
de cette enveloppe
sur le programme samedi ce qui lui
relève du mystère des commis des
finances le montant des crédits demandés
pour 2023 connaît une forte augmentation
de 632 millions d'euros à notre relation
d'engagement et les 400 75 millions
d'euros en crédit de paiement s'explique
surtout par la persistance de
l'important besoin de crédit pour
participer aussi que de refinancement
des fonds internationaux par ailleurs
les effets de la hausse des taux
d'intérêt sur le coût de bonification
des opérations de sur les coûts des
opérations de modification de près joue
aussi un rôle en effet afin de permettre
un rêve dit de prêter à des taux
concessionnelles au bénéficiaire de
l'aide au développement l'État prend en
charge par la versement de crédit de
modification la différence entre le coup
de financement de l'AFD et le taux
auquel elle prête à ces pays or dans un
contexte de remontée des taux d'intérêt
néo mondial les coûts de financement de
la FD ont augmenté alors même que pour
être considéré comme concessionnelle les
taux proposés doivent être et rester
inférieures à un seuil fixé par l'OCDE
ainsi afin de maintenir le niveau d'aide
publique au développement généré par les
prix de l'AFD le mystère des communes et
des Finances après la décision
d'accroître le montant des crédits
dédiés à la modification des prêts de
390 millions d'euros en 2023 par
ailleurs des crédits importants
alors la reconstitution des ressources
divers fonds internationaux tels que le
fond vert pour le clim enfin le
programme 365 il est dit à la
capitalisation de l'AFD comme l'an
dernier les 190 millions d'euros
demandés correspondent à une opération
de conversion des ressources financières
de l'AFD en crédit budgétaire cette
opération est totalement naître pour
efficace public en comptabilité
nationale il ne s'agit donc ni
d'accroître
ni de lui permettre d'augmenter son
objectif figée à 12 milliards d'euros
comme indiqué notre collègue et Michel
Canevet sous réserve de l'adoption de
l'avant que nous vous présentons la
correction des finances c'est important
spéciaux vous invite à adopter les clés
de la mission d'un public développement
et ceux du concours financier
merci monsieur le Président
la parole
et maintenant monsieur Hugues souris
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des affaires étrangères de la défense et
des forces armées pour 3 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues il y a en réalité
deux aspects dans cette importance
d'augmentation des crédits de la mission
aide publique au développement que les
orateurs précédents ont soulignés d'un
côté cette hausse reflète la volonté
manifestée à l'unanimité lors du vote de
la loi du 4 août 2021 de faire de la
solidarité internationale une composante
à part entière de notre action
extérieure au même titre que notre
diplomatie ou notre défense la finalité
on est simple lutter de manière
préventive contre les causes profondes
des désordre mondiaux que sont les
crises les conflits ou encore les
déplacements de population
la progression des crédits en dons de
l'Agence française de développement
permettra ainsi de renforcer cet
indispensable politique de solidarité
internationale concrètement ce sont des
crédits supplémentaires pour l'éducation
pour la santé ou encore pour
l'agriculture avec une concentration sur
les pays d'Afrique subsaharienne mais
d'un autre côté la progression des
crédits est aussi la réponse à une
situation mondiale qui se dégrade
fortement avec de multiples crises
politiques sociales et alimentaires de
l'Afrique subsaharienne à l'Afghanistan
en passant par le Moyen-Orient d'où la
forte augmentation de l'enveloppe
budgétaire gestion et sortie de crises
qui passent de 297 millions en 2022 à
730 millions d'euros en 2023 il s'agit
d'un effort de rattrapage salutaire car
malgré cette évolution conséquente la
France ne remonte au septième rang des
27 bailleurs européens il faut souligner
que nos instruments d'aide humanitaire
et d'aide au développement sont
également mis en œuvre en Europe dans la
crise actuelle dans la crise actuelle
outre aide humanitaire l'Ukraine a ainsi
bénéficié d'un prêt de 300 millions
d'euros de l'AFD dès avril 2022 il faut
se féliciter de cette réactivité qui
montre que l'agence peut être un
instrument politique capable de mettre
en œuvre rapidement les priorités du
gouvernement l'AFD a d'ailleurs
également apporté une aide significative
à la Moldavie les crédits en hausse nous
permettront donc de poursuivre ce
soutien à nos voisins agressés par la
Russie l'augmentation de ces différents
budgets peut paraître excessive à un
moment où il nous est demandé de faire
des économies mais la politique d'aide
au développement est un élément majeur
de notre action extérieure et de
l'influence française son rôle premier
et certes de venir en aide et au soutien
de peuple défavorisés mais elle a aussi
pour objet objectif d'offrir des
perspectives locales là où l'aspiration
est de rejoindre nos économies pourtant
fragiliser au total ce budget de la
pour 2023 devrait donc permettre à notre
pays de montrer son meilleur visage sur
la scène internationale le partir de
façon conséquente serait une vision
étriquée là où nous devons au contraire
nous déployer au moment où nos
adversaires attaquent notre image par
tous les moyens et sur tous les
continents ceux-ci nous donne un appui
un point d'appui pour développer un
contreditours offensif cette approbation
globale ne doit cependant pas nous
empêcher d'être vigilant sur certains
sujets en particulier la mise en oeuvre
complète des orientations de la loi du 4
août 2021 qui sera évoquée plus
précisément par mon collègue corrapeur
je vous remercie merci nous allons
poursuivre le débat on me demande de
suspendre pour les penalties entre le
Japon et la Croatie mais il n'en est pas
question donc monsieur Rachid themal
vous avez rapporteur pour avis de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense des forces armées pour trois
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame le ministre
mes chers collègues les crédits de la
mission aide publique au développement
s'inscrivent dans le cas de la loi
d'orientation de programmation relatif
au développement solidaire et lutte
contre les inégalités adoptées le 4 août
2021 loi qui doit beaucoup au travail à
l'engagement du Sénat il est temps d'en
tiré un premier bilan aussi je constate
mon propos sur quatre points d'abord sur
la trajectoire budgétaire et financière
gouvernement a fait le choix de la
modifier
elle était adoptée je rappelle par le
Sénat et dans en effet l'objectif de 07%
du revenu national brut prévu en 2025 et
maintenant reporté à 2030 il serait
intéressant de connaître les raisons et
aussi les conséquences sur les
éventuelles programmes d'action mon
second point portera sur la gouvernance
nous lançons là un véritable SOS
concernant le comité intermittel de la
coopération internationale et
développement tant de fois annoncé mais
jamais réuni depuis février 2018 cette
situation est inacceptable et elle
empêche de fait tout discussion
parlementaire sur le contrat d'optif et
de moyens de la FD pour la période
2023-25 rappelons que le précédent
contrat
a été validé six mois avant la fin du
Trianon
mon troisième point concerne les
dispositions pardon qui sont de la
volonté du statut et dont l'application
est encore parfois brumeuse je pense par
exemple au droit et à la protection de
l'enfance dispose législatif qui ne
rappelle n'est pas une option je pense
aussi aux objectifs fixés en termes de
rapport donc est prêt de la part
bilatérale et aussi de la concentration
de l'aide programmable sur les pays
prioritaires le compte est toujours pas
nous regrettons également cette année
encore qui a moins d'un tiers de la taxe
sur les transactions financières soit
consacrées au développement qui a raison
d'être d'ailleurs de cette même taxe en
revanche nous pouvons que nous féliciter
des avancées concernant les biens mal
acquis
la ligne budgétaire va être abondée avec
notamment le règlement des affaires
relatifs à la Guinée équatoriale et
Arifa el-Assad
mon quatrième point concerne la
commission d'évaluation va ce sujet
durant ces discussion notamment avec
l'astation nationale je note avait cette
faction l'amendement déposé par le
Gouvernement je crois qu'enfin la raison
de l'emporter puisque le dernier point
de blocage a été soulevé avec notamment
la question la présidence présidence que
je le rappelle
par le premier président de la Cour des
comptes avait déjà été la position qu'en
tout cas de mon groupe et de certains
d'ailleurs dès 2021 donc que le temps
perdu
madame la ministre sous réserve ces
quelques remarques et contenu de
l'effort budgétaire accompli la
commission a émis un avis favorable à
l'adoption des crédits de cette mission
je vous en remercie
merci
dans la discussion générale la parole
est maintenant madame Nicole Duranton
pour le groupe RDPI pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues l'aide
publique au développement qui nous
occupe aujourd'hui se compose de deux
programmes principaux le programme 110
aide économique et financière au
développement placé sous la
responsabilité de du ministère de
l'économie des finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle et numérique
le programme 209 solidarité à l'égard
des pays en développement qui lui est
piloté par le ministère de l'Europe et
des Affaires étrangères conformément à
la trajectoire financière tracée les
crédits de paiement affectés à ces deux
programmes sont en augmentation de plus
de 17% par rapport à la loi de finances
initiale pour 2022 pour atteindre 5,9
milliards d'euros cette augmentation
intervient à une période post crise
sanitaire où la maîtrise des dépenses de
l'État est redevenu une priorité
qui témoigne de la volonté de la France
de rester un soutien fort et fiable des
pays envoient de développement c'est un
choix rendu nécessaire par le contexte
international mais c'est aussi un choix
politiquement courageux au regard du
contexte politique national que l'on
connaît oui la France a ses propres gens
enjeux ses propres urgences et sans
doute en tout cas les résultats des
dernières élections le laisse penser une
partie de nos compatriotes voudraient se
voir tarir et même disparaître ces
crédits vers l'étranger il faut
combattre cette tentation de repli et
d'indifférence
en cela il ne s'agit pas d'approuver
simplement l'augmentation des crédits de
la mais de leur revendiquer la hausse
de 46% de l'aide économique et
financière au développement va permettre
à la France de continuer à accorder le
taux d'emprunt très bas au pays en
développement certains reprochent au
gouvernement ce choix de préférer les
prix plutôt que les dons ou les
subventions mais il s'agit de
responsabiliser les états car il n'y a
pas d'argent magique pour reprendre la
formule du président de la République
reste que l'engagement de la France dans
l'aide internationale doit rester
financièrement soutenable le périmètre
OCDE de la s'élève en 2022 à 14,8
milliards d'euros soit environ 0,55 du
revenu national brut soyons réalistes
dans la conjoncture d'inflation actuelle
il est impossible de tenir l'objectif de
0,7 pour 2025 comme recommandé par l'ONU
en effet cela se traduirait par 6,6
milliards de hausse par rapport à 2022
aussi ce texte prévoit une cible
intermédiaire de 0,61 qui semble cela
n'enlève rien à la volonté de
contribution de la France comme en
témoigne la hausse spectaculaire des
crédits de gestion de sortie de crise
qui passe à 730 millions d'euros soit
une augmentation de plus
146%. voilà un chiffre éloquent il faut
aussi souligner l'augmentation des fonds
consacrés à l'aide humanitaire qui
atteignent 642 millions d'euros contre
500 millions l'an passé soyons donc
fiers de ce budget qui est certes
davantage tourné vers l'aide humanitaire
que le développement mais qui a le
mérite de s'adapter véritablement aux
besoins de l'instant notre aide
humanitaire programmée va en effet
atteindre 635 millions d'euros 200
millions d'euros de mise en oeuvre à
travers le fond d'urgence et de
stabilisation notamment pour l'Irak ce
dont je me réjouis en tant que président
du groupe d'amitié francirac mais aussi
la Syrie la Libye le Yémen l'Afghanistan
ou encore la zone subsaharienne 160
millions d'euros pour l'aide humanitaire
programmée 200 millions d'euros dédiés
au contribution une humanitaire
volontaire aux Nations Unies 75 millions
pour le farm qui doit répondre
spécifiquement aux enjeux alimentaires
mondiaux provoqués par le conflit
ukrainien autant d'efforts budgétaires
qui permettent à la France d'occuper la
septième place parmi les 27 pays de
l'Union européenne en matière d'aide
humanitaires pour que la France
maintienne un niveau d'engagement qui
lui permet de peser dans les arbitrages
et faire entendre sa voix dans le
concert européen et international notre
groupe RDPI est favorable à l'adoption
des crédits de cette mission je vous
remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Jean-Marc audacini
pour le groupe socialiste pour 6 minutes
mesdames les ministres chers collègues
l'aide publique au développement est un
pilier de la politique étrangère de la
France et contribue à assurer la paix et
la sécurité dans le monde
cette définition émane de la loi du 4
août 2021 relative au développement
solidaire et à la lutte contre les
inégalités mondiales pour laquelle le
Sénat est plus particulièrement
particulièrement les membres de la
commission des affaires étrangères et de
la défense et des forces armées c'est
grandement mobilisé comme notamment ma
collègue marie-arlett Carlotti qui
aujourd'hui représente le Sénat dans le
cadre de l'Assemblée parlementaire de
l'OTAN et que j'associe donc à mon
intervention le Sénat a permis de
nombreux avancées bien que notre groupe
aurait souhaité sur beaucoup de points
une position plus ambitieuse cette loi
propose enfin la création d'un mécanisme
de restitution des biens malaquis les
socialistes ont beaucoup œuvré dans ce
sens et je tiens particulièrement à
rendre hommage au travail réalisé par
notre collègue Jean-Pierre Sueur
bien d'autres engagements ont été pris
dans cette loi nous attendons désormais
que chacun d'entre eux soit suivi des
faits sur la trajectoire financière de
l'aide publique au développement une
position de compromis avait été trouvée
lors des débats nous souhaitons que
celle-ci soit tenue et en regardant les
montants des crédits la trajectoire
française semble se rétrécir l'objectif
de 0,7 % est en revue à la baisse et
reporté à 2030 si la programmation votée
par le Parlement jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2022 annonce la France
s'efforcera d'atteindre 0,7% en 2025
mesdames les ministres pouvant nous
compter sur vous pour tenir cet
engagement
pour autant pourquoi le gouvernement
refuse tout financement innovant
l'augmentation de la taxe sur les
transactions financières aurait été un
signe en faveur de l'aide publique au
développement
l'élargissement de son assiette aurait
été une première marche à franchir pour
s'aligner sur ce que dit la loi et
atteindre l'objectif de 0,7 %. c'est un
combat que nous rappellerons à chaque
fois que le débat le permettra
si l'Agence Française de Développement a
pour mission de financer des projets de
développement par des dons et la corde
également une grande part de ses
financements au travers de prêt
bancaires nous soutenons la position de
nos deux corps rapporteurs hugsory et
Rachid temal de distinguer clairement
les deux missions car l'Agence française
de développement doit rester en priorité
l'outil de la solidarité de la France
envers les pays les plus pauvres tel
était sa mission lors de sa création
la loi a ciblé des pays prioritaires les
19 pays les moins avancés définies par
l'OCDE qui sont justement les pays les
plus pauvres des pays pour qui la
solidarité en don doit être prioritaire
avant les prêts bancaires car de
nombreux pays qui bénéficient de près se
trouvent dans des situations proches du
surendettement nous regrettons donc une
fois de plus le projet de loi de
finances ne rééquilibre pas la part
entre ces deux piliers les prêts et les
dons la solidarité française ne doit pas
être monnayée la situation économique
mondiale appelle plus que jamais à
l'octroi dedans plus important
l'aide publique au développement a aussi
pour objectif d'éradiquer la pauvreté de
lutter contre les inégalités de
promouvoir les droits humains de
renforcer l'État de droit c'est pourquoi
promouvoir l'enregistrement des
naissances et la mise en place des états
civils fiable doit être une priorité de
la politique de développement solidaire
de la France
mais de nombreux pays n'ont pas d'état
civil les conséquences sont dramatiques
pour les personnes qui sont privées
d'identité juridique privée d'existences
réelles il n'existe pas ils sont
vulnérables
en 2019 un rapport de l'Unicef souligné
qu'un enfant de moins de 5 ans sur 4
n'était pas enregistrés à la naissance
et que ce ratio s'accentué en Asie du
Sud et en Afrique pour ses enfants qui
deviendront des adultes invisibles sans
état civil il y aura aucun accès au
droit les plus élémentaires ils seront
vulnérables au trafic en tout genre au
mariage forcé à la prostitution nous
attendons de la France qui allait une
position ambitieuse dans la promotion de
la constitution des incivils fiables
qu'elle contribue au fond du groupe de
travail pour l'identité juridique et
concentre enfin à nous communiquer le
montant de sa contribution
enfin mesdames les ministres
permettez-moi d'avoir une pensée pour
chacun des acteurs qui oeuvrent au madis
de l'Agence française de développement
ou des organisations de la société
civile ce pays qui fut l'un des modèles
de démocratie en Afrique Vion
aujourd'hui une situation très grave la
jinte mais enseigne le rejet de la
France manipule ses opinions publiques
et laisse dépend entier de son pays aux
mains des terroristes ou des milices de
Wagner face à cette situation le que DRC
aurait décidé d'arrêter les financements
en direction d'association notoirement
anti-française mesdames les ministres
sur quels critères appuyez-vous cette
décision
quels sont ces associations combien sont
touchés par cette mesure
car cette situation nous inquiète
doublement d'autant que le gouvernement
malien même s'il est peu crédible en
disent de réponse à déclarer interdire
avec effet immédiat toutes les activités
menées par les associations les
organisations non gouvernementales et
assimilées opérant sur le territoire de
la République du Mali sur financement ou
avec l'appui matérielle ou technique de
la France
d'une part nous ne serons jamais
favorables à rompre tous les liens avec
des associations ont nagé sur le terrain
sur des projets qui contribuent le plus
souvent à maintenir à flot un embryon de
démocratie d'autre part de nombreuses
sollectivités territoriales
s'interrogent sur le devenir de leur
coopération décentralisée elles ont
besoin d'être éclairés voire confortés
mesdames les ministres je souhaite que
ce débat vous donne l'occasion de nous
apporter toutes les réponses enfin pour
conclure malgré les efforts qui restent
à faire sur le financement de l'aide
publique au développement le groupe
socialiste votera en faveur de ce budget
parce que nous ne poursuivons qu'un seul
but éradiquer la pauvreté dans le monde
merci
la parole est maintenant au président
Pierre Laurent pour le groupe CRCE pour
4 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues cette année le
budget de l'aide publique au
développement augmente de 800 millions
d'euros nous progressons donc mais nous
progressons lentement trop lentement au
point de repousser dès cette année
l'objectif des 07% faute d'avoir pu
sanctuariser une véritable programmation
budgétaire l'an dernier lors du débat de
la loi qui portait pourtant ce titre
prometteur de programmation
par ailleurs nous continuons de ne pas
corriger au fond une partie des contenus
inadaptés de cette aide publique conçu
trop souvent non pour aider les pays
destinataires à s'émanciper durablement
de leurs dépendances mes pensées d'abord
pour préserver les intérêts français
dans les régions concernées
le déséquilibre dans la répartition de
l'augmentation des crédits entre les
prêts et les dons au profit des premiers
restent manifestent ils commencent à
être corrigés comme le demandait tous
les bancs du Sénat pour concentrer
l'aide vers les pays les plus fragiles
nous proposons de mieux corriger cette
répartition dans un amendement que nous
soumettrons au vote nous proposons
également des amendements destinés à
modifier le mode de calcul des codes
parts de DTS je suis souvent intervenu
sur cette question et de leur
bonification afin d'en augmenter le
volume au profit des pays les plus
pauvres ceux qui en ont le plus besoin
tandis que des pays plus riches mieux
dotés en DTS ne les utilisent pas tous
par ailleurs nous continuons de trouver
scandaleux que le produit de la taxe sur
les transactions financières qui
devraient atteindre le record de 2,24
milliards d'euros en 2023 voit sa part
affecter au fond de solidarité pour le
développement plafonné à 528 millions
d'euros cette taxe a été créée à
l'origine pour participer à la
solidarité internationale 1, cette Maria
milliards sont donc subtilisés au
détriment de la pour servir à
rembourser une dette créée par notre
pays l'argent ira donc dans la poche des
créanciers qui vivent des intérêts de
cette dette des acteurs financiers qui
sont les mêmes qui souvent participent à
quête organisé par la dette sur le dos
des pays pauvres c'est donc un véritable
détournement pendant ce temps la crise
alimentaire mondiale pour y conduire
selon la FAO à menacé de famine 11 à 19
millions de personnes supplémentaires et
dans un contexte où pour la première
fois depuis 1990 l'extrême pauvreté
augmente et où l'indice de développement
humain a diminué pour la deuxième année
consécutive madame la ministre comment
continuer à justifier une telle
indécence dans l'utilisation de la TTF
ce n'est pas possible la France doit
prendre ses responsabilités augmenter
massivement son fond solidarité pour le
développement nous proposons ainsi de
rehausser la taxe de 0,3 07 qui
permettrait d'ajouter près d'un milliard
et demi à la ainsi que d'élargir
l'assiette pour que plus d'entre
enfin nous voulons continuer à alerter
sur les problèmes de sens de la de
critères de ciblage de pilotage de
transparence le pilotage de cette
politique doit être démocratisé son
efficacité en termes de développement
endogène pour les pays destinataires
mieux évalués dans un rapport publicié
début 2020 la Cour des comptes avait
d'ailleurs également alerté sur le
manque de transparence de toute une
série de sujets et la commission
instaurée par la loi l'an dernier avec
des parlementaires en son sein tarde
toujours à cela s'ajoute tous les
problèmes de contenu de cette aide
que j'ai évoqué enfin je terminerai mon
propos sur la décision de suspendre les
financements d'être public au
développement en direction du Mali
cette décision scandalisent à juste
titre le monde humanitaire associatif au
Mali mais aussi en France
je crois que c'est une décision
irresponsable faire ainsi payer les
frais des désaccords politiques entre
nos deux gouvernements à l'une des
populations les plus pauvres du monde
c'est une faute qui donne
malheureusement raison à une mesure que
d'ailleurs avait proposé Marine Le Pen
le 2 février dernier après le renvoi de
l'ambassadeur français du Mali cette
décision doit être vu au plus vite nous
appelons à la reprise du dialogue car
l'engrenage actuel encourt est
catastrophique pour les deux pays pour
toutes ces raisons nous ne serons pas en
mesure de voter ce budget qui progresse
trop faiblement à nos yeux et qui ne
prend pas en compte les changements de
conception que la politique de
développement mondial appelle
urgemment
merci monsieur le Président la parole
est maintenant Monsieur Jacques le nez
pour le groupe Union centriste pour 6
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues pour l'année 2023
les crédits de la mission aide publique
au développement augmenteront de 21,4 %
motorisation d'engagement et de 16% en
crédit de paiement avec ce projet de loi
de finances l'objectif annoncé par le
président de la République en 2017
d'atteindre les 0,55% de notre revenu
national brut consacré à l'aide publique
au développement est atteint nous avions
entériné cet objectif l'an dernier avec
la loi du 4 août 2021 et nous saluons
donc le respect de cet engagement la
cible de 0,7% du RNB fixé depuis 1970
par l'ONU sera quant à elle repoussée de
2025 à 2030 en raison du contexte de
crise économique
néanmoins dans ce contexte nous ne
pouvons que saluer l'augmentation forte
des crédits dédiés à l'aide humanitaire
tout particulièrement se dédier au fond
d'urgence humanitaire et de
stabilisation
ces crédits vont permettre une action
approfondie sur les trois zones de
l'Afrique du Nord du Moyen-Orient et du
Sahel et en tant que président de groupe
d'amitié François Afghanistan et membre
du groupe d'amitié francs Ukraine je ne
peux que souscrire à la création
d'enveloppes dédiées à ces deux pays qui
se trouvent dans des situations
extrêmement difficiles
ainsi dans le cas de la guerre en
Ukraine l'Agence française de
développement apporte sa pierre à l'aide
humanitaire mais aussi à l'aide au
développement non seulement en Ukraine
mais aussi en Moldavie et en Roumanie
c'est adaptabilité du groupe AFD au
changement de contexte international
doit être souligné nous ne pouvons que
nous en féliciter plus largement donc ce
sont tous les crédits de la mission qui
augmente en 2023 avec 1,4 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires en autorisation
d'engagement et 819 millions en crédit
de paiement cette augmentation
correspond aux ambitions et orientations
fixées l'an dernier dans la loi de
programmation de notre aide publique au
développement
mais s'il est encore difficile
d'apprécier réellement latin des
objectifs chiffrés le taux d'aide
bilatérale fixé à 65 % minimum de l'aide
totale n'a été atteint en 2021 d'où il
s'élevait à 60% le report de la cible de
0,7 % du RNB évoqué au début de mon
intervention pose également question le
Parlement sera-t-il associé à la
réactualisation nécessaire de la
programmation financière prévue par la
loi de la même manière la création dans
ce projet de loi de finances d'un
mécanisme de réserve pour crise majeure
dotée de 270 millions d'euros et le
bienvenu pour renforcer le dynamisme et
la réactivité de l'aide humanitaire
française mais ne doit pas devenir une
réserve de budgétisation
la loi de programmation a également mise
en avant le besoin de transparence de
notre être au développement nous nous
réjouissons donc de la mise en ligne
récente par le ministère de l'économie
et le ministère de l'Europe et les
affaires étrangères d'une base de
données ouverte pour regrouper les
informations
relatives à l'ADP de notre pays ce
travail sur la transparence a déjà été
reconnu par le gain de 5 places de l'AFD
dans le classement de l'ONG publié joie
qui analyse la transparence des
principales agences de développement
dans le monde mais il faut tout de même
souligner que la mise en place de la
Commission nationale d'évaluation se
fait attendre alors qu'elle sera un
véritable instrument de transparence et
d'efficacité de notre politique de
développement solidaire et de lutte
contre les inégalités mondiales
et alors que la France vit une crise
d'influence notamment en Afrique
continent prioritaire de notre politique
de développement il est nécessaire de
renforcer davantage et transparence il
est aussi indispensable de mettre en
avant notre politique de développement
et notre apport à la solidarité
internationale par des actions de
communication à destination des
populations
bénéficiant des projets notamment les
jeunes générations
l'augmentation de la bilatérale doit
aller de pair avec une lutte contre la
désinformation l'encontre de la France
cette affirmation est particulièrement
vrai au Sahel ou la stratégie 3D à mal
fonctionné notamment dans la
coordination entre la défense et le
développement et où nos efforts
politiques ou militaires ont été
refoulés comme l'illustre aujourd'hui la
crise profonde avec les autorités
maliennes
le 16 novembre dernier tous les projets
de développement français ont été
suspendus au Mali pour éviter tout
risque de détournement on peut
s'interroger sur la suite des événements
que vont devenir les projets en cours et
les financements prévus le Sénat restera
attentif aux orientations données à la
politique de développement français tout
particulièrement lors du prochain comité
interministériel de la coopération
internationale et du développement qui
devrait prendre place au début de
l'année prochaine
estimant tout de même que les
augmentations de crédit de la mission
APD suivent les orientations exprimées
dans la loi du 4 août 2021 le groupe
Union Centris votera ses crédit
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur Stéphane Ravier pour
les non inscrits pour 3 minutes
monsieur le Président Madame le ministre
mes chers collègues
sont départements de Mayotte est en
proie à la guerre civile son
gouvernement qui annonce la fermeture
des écoles en raison des coupures de
l'électricité ces 3000 milliards d'euros
de dettes sont systèmes de santé au bord
de la faillite un en sauvagement de son
quotidien son ministre de l'économie qui
déclara être à l'Europe le premier pays
tiers mon disait que la France devrait
aider mes chers collègues c'est
précisément la France mais les crédits
de paiement de la mission aide publique
au pays en développement qu'on a une
hausse de 16% pour l'année à venir sans
renoncer à notre politique d'influence
humanitaire à l'étranger et à un
nécessaire soft power à la française ce
budget devrait être agite ajusté au
contexte national de tension financière
exceptionnelle il m'est impossible de se
tenir le projet contesté d'un nouveau
siège pour l'Agence française de
développement l'AFD qui coûterait 1
milliard d'euros au contribuable
français un milliard c'est ce que
Emmanuel Macron a refusé d'investir en
2019 pour financer le nucléaire du futur
sacrifiant ainsi notre indépendance
énergétique je vais lancer également les
41 millions d'euros versés à la Turquie
dans le cadre du mécanisme d'accueil des
réfugiés syriens alors que le sultan
Erdogan ne se prive pas de faire du
chantage au clandestin en nos frontières
européennes et de soutenir l'invasion de
l'Arménie par l'Azerbaïdjan par ailleurs
je vois mal l'intérêt de financer une
aduanitaire en Afghanistan totalement
sous l'emprise des talibans car nous
n'avons aucun contrôle sur la
destination de cette aide cependant la
question n'est pas uniquement de celle
de savoir combien nous dépensons mais
comment nous le dépensons en effet le
retour sur investissement de cette
dépense publique est gravement mis en
cause pour avoir tiré la sonnette
d'alarme chaque année je peux vous dire
que je regrette chaque euro dépensé pour
le Mali qui nous l'a rendu par la haine
par la haine de la France de sa
population et de son gouvernement cela
doit nous servir de leçon la République
au développement doit être conditionnée
à nos intérêts afin de garantir la
sécurité de notre territoire en
contrôlant les trafics et les flux
humains bien en amont elle doit être
conditionnée l'acceptation automatique
par les États bénéficiaires dans leurs
étrangers expulsés de notre territoire
national n'ayant pas de conduite à tenir
clair l'AFD ne se soucie pas de soutenir
les entreprises et l'industrie française
lorsqu'elles financent un projet à
l'étranger c'est tout à fait déplorable
en outre le président de la République
vient de déclarer que la France allait
débloquer une enveloppe d'un milliard
d'euros pour aider l'Afrique du Sud à
sortir du charbon alors que ces choix
ont entraînés la réouverture de
centrales à charbon sur notre sol
regardons la poutre qui est dans notre
œil plutôt que le charbon qui est celui
dans ce qui est dans celui du voisin il
y a tant à faire dans notre pays en
matière de développement il faut que
chaque euro dépenser à l'étranger sert
au développement du pays en savoir-faire
en infrastructure pour que les
populations se fixent deviennent
autonome et prospère en définitive
favorable à la réduction de la dépense
publique je voterai contre cette mission
du projet de loi de finance qui réserve
la générosité nationale aux autres
plutôt que notre
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant monsieur André Guillaume pour
le groupe RDS pour 4 minutes
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames les
ministres mes chers collègues cette
mission s'inscrit au coeur des valeurs
que la France défend celle de solidarité
ainsi que celle du respect des droits
humains des valeurs pas partagées par
tous en tant que pays développés pour ne
pas dire riche nous avons le devoir de
préserver une aide au développement
ambitieuse en faveur du droit à une vie
digne pour tous
mes collègues rapporteurs ont souligné
les chiffres qui confirment la hausse du
soutien de la France les crédits de la
mission de l'aide publique au
développement augmenteront de 16,04% en
avec un montant de 14,8 milliards
d'euros d'aide remontant répondant aux
critères de l'OCDE on peut se réjouir
que notre pays est rempli en 2022 son
objectif d'une aide de porter à 0,55% du
revenu national brut conformément la loi
de programmation du 4 août
2021 cependant comme pour toutes les
missions budgétaires l'inflation hélas
imprime sa marque en effet en raison de
la situation économique actuelle
l'objectif de 0,7% du RNB est décalé de
2025 à 2030
c'est bien entendu regrettable mais
espérons qu'il sera possible de
réinscrire au plus vite nos moyens dans
une trajectoire dynamique en attendant
il me semble essentiel que les crédits
proposés se concentrent sur les zones
prioritaires définies par le comité
interministériel de la coopération
internationale et du développement de
2018 réaffirmé depuis à cet égard madame
la ministre notre politique de
développement solidaire est-elle bien
concentrée vers les 19 pays prioritaires
quasiment tous situés en Afrique le
Sénat souvent souligné la difficulté à
faire passer les priorités géographiques
dans les faits puisqu'il n'y a pas si
longtemps les pays les plus pauvres ne
recevaient que 15% de la pourtant
conformément l'article 2 de la loi du 4
août 2021 25% de l'aide programmable
devra bénéficier à ces pays en 2025
c'est le choix de la France que mon
groupe RDSE partage même si nous ne
cachons pas certains de ces pays sont
parfois amères je pense à ce qui se
passe au Mali pays dans lequel l'image
de la France est injustement abîmée il
convient toutefois de ne pas renoncer ne
mettons pas en avant nos liens passés
avec des continents africains qui a
parfois tendance à irriter regardons
plutôt l'Afrique pour ce qu'elle est
aujourd'hui le cœur de tous les défis
démographique économique et climatique
c'est un continent où les vulnérabilités
socio-économiques sont structurels dans
la plupart des États néanmoins beaucoup
de pays africains ont une formidable
capacité de résilience comme on
l'observe actuellement au Bangladesh
c'est assez cet esprit de partenariat
que nous devons les accompagner dans
leur développement sur la base d'une
coopération plus moderne qu'il faut sans
doute mieux expliquer aux populations à
l'aide de nos outils d'influence
l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est de ne pas
laisser celle-ci s'enfoncer dans la
crise la terre l'agression russe en
Ukraine crée une situation dramatique en
particulier au Sahel et dans la Corne de
l'Afrique je salue donc la hausse des
crédits de l'aide alimentaire au sein de
la mission enfin mes chers collègues je
rappellerai que faire œuvre de
solidarité au développement ce n'est pas
une œuvre de charité c'est une
responsabilité que nous avons en tant
que pays du Nord eu égard en un autre
modèle de développement qui a mis la
planète en danger il faut bien le dire
aussi je me réjouis de l'avancée de la
cop2 de la cop27 sur le fond de pertes
et dommages pour les pays du Sud touchés
par les dégâts du au dérèglement
climatique le RDSE compte sur vous
madame la ministre pour que ce projet ne
reste pas une coquille vide car sans
cela la gestion des conflits verts
deviendra un défi imminent le RDSE
votera donc les crédits de la mission je
vous remercie
merci chers collègues la parole est
maintenant Monsieur Bruno Sido pour le
groupe les républicains pour 7 minutes
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
rapporteurs chers collègues
pandémie du covid-19 changement
climatique accéléré
insécurité alimentaire grandissante
terrorisme guerre et regain de tension
internationale choc énergétique
surendettement inflation la liste des
crises qui secoue le monde ces dernières
années semble le plus de voir s'arrêter
de croître inévitablement leurs
conséquences humaines s'agourdissent et
rendent plus que jamais nécessaire
l'aide internationale en faveur des pays
les plus fragiles la France qui se
classe au cinquième rang mondial des
bailleurs de fonds a d'ailleurs consenti
depuis 10 ans des efforts considérables
pour se hisser à la hauteur de cet enjeu
songeons ainsi qu'en 2014 le volume
global de ces engagements au titre de
l'aide publique au développement était
de 8 milliards d'euros soit 0,37% de son
revenu national brut en 2022 il était
passé selon les rapporteurs spéciaux à
13 milliards d'euros et représenter 0,51
du RNB l'année prochaine cette montée en
puissance sera une nouvelle fois
intensifiée pour dépasser les 15
milliards d'euros et s'établir à 0,55%
du RMB les crédits de la mission
budgétaire est publique au développement
ne constitue qu'une partie bien que de
substantielle de ce vaste ensemble pour
2023 le gouvernement propose de les
augmenter de manière très conséquente de
l'ordre de 16% en crédit de paiement
cette orientation à la hausse si nos
partages pas tout à fait le volume je
reviendrai le groupe les républicains en
soutiendra toutefois le principe tout
d'abord parce que c'est précisément dans
la tourmente que notre contribution au
développement et notre solidarité en
matière humanitaire sont les plus
essentiels en effet les pays les plus
fragiles sont largement et parfois
totalement dépourvu des moyens
nécessaires pour amortir les effets de
crise leur population a déjà plus
vulnérable sont donc de fait les plus
menacés les soutenir face aux
soubresauts qui agitent le monde comme
nous le faisons par exemple en Ukraine
et donc une exigence morale à laquelle
nous ne pouvons nous soustraire mais
permettez-moi de souligner qu'il s'agit
aussi de notre intérêt dans une économie
globalisée la prospérité des uns ne peut
aller ne peut aller durablement de pair
avec la paupérisation des autres en
stimulant la vitalité économique et la
hausse du niveau de vie dans les pays en
développement se sont aussi des
partenariats que nous créons et les
conditions d'un échange économique plus
soutenu avec la France que nous
favorisons en autre ne nous
sous-estimons pas le fait que l'aide au
développement est également une
contribution apportée à la sécurité
internationale c'est particulièrement
vrai en Afrique subsaharienne qui est à
la fois zone d'action prioritaires de la
FD et théâtre principal des opérations
extérieures que nous avons engagées
depuis 10 ans il est né les populations
à satisfaire leurs besoins fondamentaux
se nourrir se soigner s'éduquer et
contribuer à ce qu'elle bénéficie de
perspective économique c'est en partie
assécher le terreau sur lequel se
développe les mouvements de jihadistes
contre lesquels nos soldats continuent
de lutter c'est aussi ne l'oublions pas
contribuer à dessiner un avenir qui ne
passe pas automatiquement par les routes
migratoires au moment où l'opération
barkhane s'achève officiellement de
nombreuses enseignements doivent
toutefois être tirés de l'action de
notre pays dans la région car son bilan
s'il est plus honorable d'un point de
vue militaire est en revanche
politiquement jamais la France n'était
tant critiquée tant contester tant
rejeter et pas seulement au Mali au
Burkina Faso ou dans le reste du Sahel
c'est bien dans l'ensemble de l'Afrique
qu'elle perd progressivement pied face à
ce recul et qui ne cesse de s'accélérer
la redéfinition d'une politique
africaine globale et désormais urgente
elle devra nécessairement inclure une
nouvelle réflexion sur les résultats de
la politique d'aide au développement que
nous y menons c'est d'autant plus
essentiel que le volume les modalités
les objectifs de l'aide économique revêt
une dimension stratégique qui ne fait
que s'affirmer elle est devenue en
particulier sur ce continent un enjeu à
part entière dans la lutte d'influence
que ce livre les grandes puissances dont
certaines ne ménagent pas à leurs
efforts pour nous concurrencer voir nous
évincer une aide au développement
revisitée doit donc nous permettre de
retrouver dans cette partie du monde les
leviers d'action qui nous a peu à peu
voilà brosser à grand trait a pas de
raison qui amène notre groupe à soutenir
malgré l'extrême difficulté du contexte
économique un nouveau renforcement des
crédits de la mission aide publique au
développement parce que c'est une
réponse au risque créé par des crises
qui se multiplient et se combinent parce
que c'est un instrument de rayonnement
et d'influence de la France parce que
c'est aussi l'expression des
orientations définies par la loi de
programmation du 4 août 2021 que le
Sénat avait adopté à la quasi inanimité
je vous le rappelle celle-ci portait
notamment l'ambition d'engager à partir
de 2025 un montant d'aide équivalent à
0,7% du RNB mais cet objectif compte
tenu des évolutions radicales de la
conjoncture intervenue depuis le vote de
la loi semble désormais hors de portée
et le gouvernement a décidé d'en
reporter la réalisation à 2030
concernant la unité qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui celle de 2023 la cible
initialement fixée à 0,61% du RNB a en
conséquence été ramené un niveau plus
souten de
0,55%. la dégradation importante de nos
comptes publics l'impact de l'inflation
et le risque de récession de plus en
plus prégnant ne laisse à la vérité pas
d'autres alternatives il ne reste pas
moins que le gouvernement propose en
crédit de paiement de mobiliser 8008
millions d'euros supplémentaires au
bénéfice de la mission qui atteindrait
ainsi un total de 5,9 milliards d'euros
en 2023 cette augmentation s'inscrit
dans un cadre général qui est celui du
projet de loi de programmation des
finances publiques or la majorité
sanatoriale a contesté il y a un mois
l'économie générale de ce texte estimant
qu'il ne conduisait pas à réduire le
déficit public dans des délais
suffisants le budget général pour 2023
construit sur cette base doit donc être
réviser pour être conforme à la
trajectoire de la maîtrise des dépenses
retenue par notre assemblée en
conséquence les crédits de la mission
aide publique au développement
nous considérons qu'ils doivent rester
en hausse peuvent être raisonnablement
mis à contribution c'est pourquoi dans
le cadre d'une approche globale et
cohérente notre groupe proposera par
voie d'amendement de fixer leur
progression à 618 millions d'euros
l'année prochaine c'est nous sommes
utile une voie équilibrée pour
satisfaire à deux exigences en apparence
peu conciliables d'un côté réaffirmer
notre engagement à faire plus pour la
solidité la solidarité internationale de
l'autre agir résolument pour restaurer
la responsabilité et la crédibilité
budgétaire de notre pays je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est maintenant Monsieur Joël guerriot
pour le groupe les indépendants pour 4
minutes
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues rapator spéciaux
mesdames et messieurs depuis des années
la France figure parmi les premiers pays
contributeurs à l'aide musique et
publique au développement elle est
consacre des sommes importantes pour
améliorer le sort des pays les moins
avancés cette aide fait une énorme
différence pour ceux qui la reçoivent
c'est évidemment le cas de l'aide
d'urgence délivré dans un contexte de
crise humanitaire elle permet de sauver
des vies dans des contextes moins tendus
cette aide permet à des populations
d'améliorer leurs conditions de vie en
construisant des infrastructures
essentielles enfin l'aide de la France
permet à de nombreux pays de développer
leur économie en encourageant la
création d'entreprises cette aide est
bien plus que de la philanthropie dans
la mesure où elle contribue à la
sécurité des populations les zones les
plus défavorisées sont en effet les plus
sujettes au développement de conflit
armés ceux qui n'ont rien n'ont rien à
perdre c'est cette action est utile et
si elle est toute à l'honneur de notre
pays elle a un coût en 2022 la France il
y en a consacré 13 milliards d'euros
c'est à dire
0,51% de son revenu national brut il
s'agit d'un effort important
particulièrement dans un contexte
économique difficile
cinquième contributeur à l'aide publique
au développement la France n'est
pourtant pas la 5e puissance économique
devant sépare l'Inde nous sommes à
présent 7e alors que nous visons
toujours l'objectif de consacrer 0,7% de
notre revenu national brut au
développement la question des moyens se
pose et notre rapporteur Michel Calvet
l'a rappelé tout à l'heure qu'il serait
très difficile d'atteindre cet objectif
la plupart des économistes s'accordent à
dire que la croissance mondiale sera
faible dans les années à venir la France
sera-t-elle aussi confrontée à de
sérieuses difficultés économiques très
endettés elle est particulièrement
affectée par la remontée des taux
d'intérêt
la question de la soutenabilité de cette
aide se pose donc l'autre sujet et celui
des objectifs de l'aide à portée par la
France nous avons été plusieurs à
souligner que c'était doit être destinée
au pays quand nous le plus besoin elle
doit aussi être orientée vers des
projets qui servent nos intérêts ces
dernières années la France a fait
l'objet de campagne hybride visant à
nuire son image force et de constater
que ses campagnes ont eu un certain
effet
il nous paraît donc essentiel que l'aide
publique au développement financé par le
contriable contribuable français fasse
l'objet d'un contrôle strict et n'aille
pas renforcer la gouvernance de pays qui
affichent de l'hostilité à l'égard de la
France aux côtés de l'État nos
collectivités territoriales contribuent
aussi nous rappelons-le de plus en plus
à l'aide publique de la France elles le
font notamment au travers de projets
centrés sur leurs compétences comme la
gestion de l'eau les collectivités
consacrent également plusieurs dizaines
de millions d'euros à l'aide des
demandeurs d'asile et des réfugiés sans
compter l'aide médicale d'État qui
permet à toute personne sur le français
de bénéficier de soins gratuits la
France dans toutes ses composantes
contribuent donc beaucoup à l'aide au
développement elle doit contribuer de
l'effet avec des moyens et au bénéfice
de projets qui servent ces intérêts
voilà pourquoi le groupe Les
Indépendants votera en faveur de
l'adoption des crédits de cette mission
merci cher collègue
la parole est maintenant au président
Guillaume gonta pour le groupe
écologiste pour 4 minutes
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues nous concluons ce
marathon budgétaire sur une note un peu
plus positive la mission aide publique
au développement enregistre une des plus
fortes hausses de ce budget après avec
près de 17% de crédits supplémentaires
certes les formes ne permet pas
d'atteindre l'objectif de consacrer
0,60% du revenu national brut à l'aide
au développement tel que le prévoyait la
trajectoire de la loi de programmation
aide publique au développement de 2021
certes l'objectif d'atteindre enfin le
07% du RNB en 2025 semble largement
compromis
néanmoins je ne suis pas d'avis comme
nos rapporteurs de la commission des
finances de réviser dès à présent cette
trajectoire même si la marché haute la
France doit tout faire pour tenir cet
objectif qui rappelons-le est une
promesse non tenue depuis plus d'un
demi-siècle ou tu du moins s'en
approcher au plus près
considérant le contexte géopolitique et
économique qui succèdent à la pandémie
ne tenons pas rigueur au gouvernement de
ne pas avoir respecté cette trajectoire
en effet l'augmentation brute de 1,4
milliards d'euros en autorisation
d'engagement et de 819 millions d'euros
en crédit de paiement constituent un
signal positif
dans le détail le programme 110 augmente
de 390 millions les tailles en fait le
choix de bonifier les prix de l'AFD pour
faire face à la remontée des taux
d'intérêt c'était nécessaire mais cela
interroge encore et toujours sur le
recours trop important auprès auprès de
notre APD plutôt que de favoriser les
dons le programme 209 relatif à la
solidarité avec les pays en
développement augmente lui de 433
millions dont 270 pour la création d'un
fond d'urgence pour faire face aux
crises qui semblent particulièrement
opportun dans le climat actuel
contrairement à nos rapporteur si
d'aventure ces crédits n'étaient pas
consommés je ne vois pas difficultés à
ce qu'il constitue au contraire une
réserve budgétaire pour d'autres actions
du programme et je me pose d'ailleurs
avec force à leur amendement visant à
réduire de 200 millions les crédits du
programme 209 nous sommes déjà en retard
par rapport à la trajectoire budgétaire
que nous avons adopté à la quasi
unanimité ici il serait totalement
incohérent de redire enveloppe
aujourd'hui je salue en revanche la
priorité mise dans les actions de la
mission vers les besoins prioritaires
que sont l'éducation et la santé avec
des augmentations de crédit de 122 et
336,4 millions pour respecter les
engagements de la France pour le
Partenariat mondial pour les pour
l'éducation et pour reconstituer le fond
mondial de lutte contre le sida la
tuberculose et le paludisme seul 18% de
notre APD est aujourd'hui tourné vers
les services sociaux de base cet effort
est appelé à être massivement amplifié
le présent préger prévoit près d'un
milliard d'euros pour le fond vert pour
le climat afin de permettre à la France
de tenir à la dernière minute la
promesse formulée par Emmanuel Macron en
2019 au G7 de Biarritz d'abonder ce fond
de 1,5 milliards d'euros sur la période
2019-2023
c'est un pas en avant et il faudra
poursuivre sur cet élan COP après COP
les discussions à chopes sur la
solidarité des pays industrialisés avec
les pays en développement nous apprêtons
enfin en 2023 à tenir la promesse de 100
milliards par an 7 à Copenhague en 2019
alors que la cop27 a accouché dans la
douleur d'un petit dernier un judicieux
fond perte et préjudice à destination
des pays vulnérables mais qui demeure
intégralement et rapidement à construire
nous espérons que la France sera moteur
dès le prochain PF pour lui donner une
consistance sonnante et trébuchante
madame la ministre groupe écologiste
votera les crédits de la mission en
gardant une attention particulière et en
appelant le quai à la plus grande
vigilance sur les projets financés par
la FD et Proparco pour éviter comme nous
avons failli le faire à kaouzi Biega en
RDC de nous rendre complice d'atrocité
et en continuant à plaider pour que
notre aide publique prenne davantage la
forme de dons priorise les pays cibles
les services sociaux de base la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique et
respecte les populations locales
notamment les peuples autochtones merci
merci
la discussion générale est close la
parole est maintenant au gouvernement
pour 10 minutes notamment et d'abord à
Madame Catherine colonnat ministre de
l'Europe et des Affaires étrangères
monsieur le Président Mesdames Messieurs
décidément les rapporteurs et co
rapporteurs pardonnez-moi mesdames les
sédatrices car il y en a messieurs les
sénateurs quelques éléments sur la
mission et le public au développement et
la secrétaire d'État complétera avec
votre autorisation monsieur le Président
je ne vais pas revenir sur la situation
internationale nous l'avons évoqué
lorsque nous traitions de la mission
action extérieure de l'État
je me félicite que l'augmentation de nos
moyens budgétaires se concentre
largement sur les missions être publique
au développement vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le rapporteur spécial cette
mission se compose de deux programmes le
programme 110 aident économique et
financière au développement porté par le
ministère de l'économie des finances et
de la souveraineté industrielle et
numérique et le programme 209 solidarité
à l'égard des pays en développement qui
relèvent du Quai d'Orsay ce programme
209 bénéficierait d'une augmentation de
383,1 millions d'euros
ce programme atteindrait ainsi trois
milliards 436 et deviendrait donc
prépondérant dans le budget du ministère
ce qui me semble une bonne chose au
total des deux programmes cumulés de la
mission APD qui est pilotée par ce
ministère et regroupe les deux
programmes 209 et 110 atteindrée 5
milliards 77 cela représente une hausse
de 17% par rapport à 2022 et un
doublement des crédits budgétaires de la
mission et de publique au développement
par rapport à 2017 c'est une source de
fierté pour notre pays avec ses moyens
supplémentaires le Quai d'Orsay va
pouvoir poursuivre deux objectifs
majeurs la participation de la France à
la gestion des enjeux globaux et sa
contribution et la réduction des
fractures qui déstabilise le monde
s'agissant des enjeux globaux la France
en tant continué à contribuer activement
elle a définition et la mise en oeuvre
des réponses internationales à leur
apporter j'évoquerai d'abord le climat
des filles absolues comme la montrait la
cop27 qui vient de s'achever il y a
quelques jours la France devrait
consacrer 6 milliards d'euros par an sur
la période
2021-2025 donc un tiers 2 milliards pour
l'adaptation au changement climatique
dans le cadre de cet effort la France a
augmenté massivement sa contribution au
fond pour l'environnement mondial
passant de deux sept millions d'euros
après de 300 millions d'euros par an sur
le prochain cycle 2023 2026 et comme l'a
annoncé le président de la République
aurait sans sommet du G20 nous allons
aussi accueillir en j'ai eu un prochain
un sommet sur le nouveau pacte financier
avec le sud qui sera très largement
consacrée à la question de la finance
climat en outre alors que ce tiendra
dans quelques jours la COP15
biodiversité à Montréal la France
souhaite renforcer sa mobilisation pour
la protection de la nature d'ici
2030% de l'ensemble des financements
bilatéraux français pour le climat
auront un impact bénéfique pour la
biodiversité le président de la
République s'y est engagé vous vous en
souvenez lors du sommet one Planet
Summit de janvier 2021 je signale enfin
que la deuxième reconstitution du fond
vert pour le climat interviendra en 2023
une nouvelle hausse de notre
contribution permettrait de préserver le
rang de la France et de marquer la
priorité donnée à l'action climatique
des moyens sont d'ores et déjà prévus
sur le programme 110 la santé maintenant
santé qui reste le premier poste de
l'aide publique au développement
françaises la France est résolument
engagée dans le renforcement de
l'architecture multilatérale de la santé
avec ses partenaires européens que ce
soit sur le plan multilatéral en
particulier avec l'OMS ou sur le plan
bilatéral notamment et principalement en
Afrique sur ce point je dois signaler
que la nouvelle contribution française
au fond mondial de lutte contre le sida
la tuberculose et le paludisme s'élève
pour la période 2023-2025 à 1 milliard 6
d'euros soit une hausse de 23% par
rapport à 2019
s'agissant de l'alimentation le problème
de la fin qui touche 10% de la
population mondiale est aggravée
évidemment par l'invasion de l'Ukraine
cette année 205 millions de personnes
seraient en situation de crise
alimentaire dans 45 pays selon l'ONU en
particulier en Afrique de l'Ouest afin
d'y répondre la France compte mobiliser
en 2023 des moyens supplémentaires via
le canal de l'aide alimentaire
programmée laquelle passerait de 118
millions d'euros en 2022 à 160 en 2023
et nous souhaitons également renouveler
notre contribution à l'initiative Pharma
s'agissons maintenant de notre
contribution à la réduction des
fractures elle passera largement par
l'aide humanitaire notre capacité à
répondre aux crises humanitaires que la
guerre en Ukraine là aussi a rendu
encore plus grave et aujourd'hui un
enjeu majeur notre aide humanitaire
pourrait atteindre
642 millions d'euros sur trois canaux
principaux
outre l'enveloppe d'aide alimentaire
programmée le soutien à l'initiative
farm pour 75 millions d'euros je viens
de mentionner 200 millions d'euros
seraient mis en oeuvre par le fond
d'urgence et de stabilisation portée par
notre centre de crise et mis en œuvre
par les ONG et 200 millions sera
consacrés au contributions volontaire
humanitaire aux organisations des
Nations Unies soit plus 19 millions et
demi
afin d'être les plus réactifs possibles
cette programmation c'est doublée de la
constitution d'une provision pour crise
majeure que nous proposons cette année
de décupler je crois que c'est un geste
fort en la portant de 23 millions
d'euros cette année 2022 à 270 en 2023
au total ce sont donc potentiellement
912 millions d'euros qui pourraient être
consacrés elle a du maitnitaire en 2023
là aussi c'est une source de fierté pour
notre pays mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je conclurai
en rappelant si vous votez votre budget
que notre diplomatie aura ainsi des
moyens de ses ambitions ce budget
reflète les fortes attentes à l'égard de
notre diplomatie mais aussi je crois la
confiance que lui témoigne notre
autorités une confiance qui doit
beaucoup et même sans doute tout au sens
de l'intérêt général que les agents de
mon ministère ont chevillé au corps et
donc ils apportent chaque jour la preuve
en France comme à l'étranger et dont je
veux les remercier devant vous je vous
remercie merci Madame la Ministre la
parole est maintenant madame
chrysolazakoro pouloulou secrétaire
d'État chargé du développement la
francophonie des partenariats
internationaux pour 3 minutes 24
les budgets qui nous avons l'honneur de
vous présenter souligner une sauce notre
politique de développement constitue une
véritable priorité politique du
gouvernement à 5 ans nous avons doublé
les crédits de la mission aide publique
au développement c'est la représente une
os historique de 2,5 milliards d'euros
et surtout nous allons tenir
l'engagement pris par les présidents de
la République en 2018 en consacrant
0,55% de notre revenu national à l'APD
en 202
comme les voyait nous investons donc
plus mais surtout nous en restons mieux
notre APD comprend désormais davantage
d'aide bilatéral et de dons c'est dans
son dirigés vers les pays les plus
vulnérables particulièrement les pays du
continent africains
du développement humain tels que
l'éducation et la santé nous
investissons mieux en renforçant
l'expertise technique nous renforçant en
même temps les liens humains entre notre
pays et les pays partenaires en donnant
plus de moyens à nos ambassades nous les
permettons de porter des projets
concrets et visibles au plus près des
besoins des populations depuis 5 ans
nous ne faisons pas seulement plus et
mieux nous appelons surtout une nouvelle
méthode
désormais nous veillons à travailler
avec les pays du Sud pour soutenir leur
initiative et répondre à leurs besoins
il s'agit pour nous d'accompagner ces
pays pour élever ensemble les grandes
défis globaux qui évoquaient la ministre
colonne
je pense par exemple à ceux qui nous
avons réalisé durant la pandémie pour la
vaccination des pays des Suds nous avons
aussi nous réunir en europeenne pour
habiller les renforcements des capacités
africaines de production de vaccins je
pense aussi à la grande morale verte
projet porté par les pays du Sahel pour
effacer les résilience climatiques et
agricoles face au changement climatique
elle nous demandons à chacun de nos
opérateurs notamment l'Agence française
du développement de mettre en oeuvre
cette approche pour chaque française et
chaque Français cette politique de
développement doit être une fierté elle
fait rayonner nos idéaux de solidarité
mais au-delà de cette fierté mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs cette politique
de développement nous permet directement
de protéger les Français et leur intérêt
nous vivons dans un monde interdépendant
lorsqu'on est renforçant le système de
santé des pays des Sud c'est la santé de
nos concitoyens qui nous protégeons
lorsque nous protégeons les forêts du
Bassin du Congo c'est notre climat aussi
qui nous préservons investir dans le
développement trouver des nouveaux
alliés c'est la meilleure manière de
faire peser notre vision du monde celle
de la coopération des multilatéralisme
du respect de la souveraineté du 50
cette vision c'est celle de la France
cette vision c'est celle de l'Europe
ceci la visionne que vous c'est notaire
et paramétaire vous avez approuvé alors
unanimité avons tant la loi du 4 août
2021 Mesdames et Messieurs les
sénataires avons tant ces budgets nous
renforcerons les moyens de cette
ablutions collective je vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
nous passons au débat sur les
amendements avec d'abord deux
amendements identiques le 4 monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur au nom
de la commission des finances oui
monsieur le Président Mesdames chers
collègues cela a été dit par plusieurs
orateurs durant de la discussion
générale les crédits de l'aide publique
au développement augmente assez
significativement on le constate bien
sûr depuis l'année dernière mais aussi
sur les crédits 2022 et encore en
perspective en 2023 mais il ne vous a
pas échappé que la commission des
finances est sensible à l'état des
finances publiques nous l'avons dit
notamment lors de l'examen de la loi de
programmation pluriannuelle des finances
publiques et nous leur dirons bien
entendu à cette occasion on la redit
également en différentes circonstances
lors d'examens du projet de loi de
finance et donc ceci appelle à notre
sens un effort important pour essayer de
réduire nos dépenses publiques et donc
il nous paraît logique qu'une mission
augmentant significativement ses moyens
participent également à cette volonté de
maîtrise de la dépense publique et c'est
pour cela que la commission des finances
vous propose un amendement visant à
réduire de 200 millions d'euros les
crédits dédiés
au développement 100 millions d'euros en
moins sur les projets qui restera encore
doté de 930 millions qui a augmenté
significativement entre 2021 et 2022 et
puis 100 millions d'euros également sur
les crédits dit d'urgence il en restera
encore
170 millions réserves et 630 millions
grosso modo pour pouvoir faire face à
différentes situations vous comprenez
donc que il faut à la fois avoir une
maîtrise la plus proche possible des
perspectives budgétaires c'est le sens
de l'amendement que nous proposons en
prélevant les crédits sur ce que je
viens d'indiquer et puis de conserver
néanmoins une politique volontariste en
donc d'être plus au développement
cela porteur le 499 monsieur le
Président Rapin
je pourrais dire monsieur le Président
Madame le Ministre qu'il est défendu
dans le même esprit bien sûr avec cette
demande d'économie de la commission des
finances puisque la commission des
finances je le rappelle c'était fixé un
objectif
de réduction du déficit public à 3% des
2025 et donc cet effort doit commencer
dès maintenant sur ce budget là et donc
au titre de ce qu'a dit déjà le
rapporteur il est demandé en fait une
diminution des crédits de 200 millions
d'euros ce qui grève certes les
ambitions proposées mais pas tant que ça
puisque le budget reste en augmentation
merci
Monsieur temal
ah pardon pardon à vie du gouvernement
dans la ministre sur ces deux
abonnements identiques merci Monsieur
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Center le gouvernement et défavorable à
cet amendement ça vous ne serez pas
surpris de cela la baisse des crédits
seraient contre-courant de la dynamique
d'augmentation de la part de notre RnB
consacré à la et de plus remettre
en question dès 2023 l'objectif fixé
dans la loi y compris si je me souviens
bien avec le plein d'assentiment voire
même plus de votre route assemblée
paraîtrait contradictoire avec la loi
même du 4 août 2021
merci donc Monsieur temal
Merci monsieur le Président
c'est vrai que c'est assez particulier
ce que l'on vit ce soir parce que
le 4 août 2021 nous avons voté unean
quasiment ce texte de loi et je crois
que derrière tout le monde était fier de
que la France trouve sa place on peut
dire pas suffisamment mais en tout cas
suffisamment dans j'ai envie de dire
dans ça de la place internationale je
rappelle que être une grande puissance
on l'a vu ce matin c'est également faire
de la défense mais on le dit si les 3D
donc c'est aussi du développement et la
France quand ils engagements atteint un
sono bilatéraux et donc là on a un
sentiment que je sais pas si le choléra
gravier est parti mais quand même
sous-entendu on va pas aider les autres
parce que on a chez nous c'est un vieux
débat assez dangereux je dois le
rappeler et d'ailleurs quand certains
évoquent aujourd'hui le fait que la
situation des sciences publiques
françaises fait que pour moins aider les
autres je le dis c'est un point de
départ qui me paraît inquiétant donc
aujourd'hui nous dire comme cela on met
200 millions on rabote
vous dites il y a suffisamment d'aide
mais je rappelle qu'elles engagements
aujourd'hui concrètement qui sont portés
dans des fonds et aussi des engagements
bilatéraux et moi je plais en plus par
ailleurs pour que la part des dons
soient plus importantes donc moi je
trouve que c'est un moment là est très
dangereux et très dangereux il n'a pas
été d'ailleurs en plus très honnêtement
je vais me permettre de le dire j'aurais
aimé que la Commission de finance la
commission d'affaires étrangère et de la
défense se parle découvert comme cela un
coup de rabot alors que nous sommes deux
rapporteurs avec huxory à travailler sur
ces questions là on a fait tous
travailler là pour que la loi avance on
fait en sorte qu'il y a une commission
de contrôler d'évaluation etc et puis
parce que j'ai le sentiment que des
enjeux autres autre que ce lier à
l'intérêt du développement vont essayer
de primer ce soir donc je vous appelle
vraiment mes chers collègues pour le
coup à ne pas à retirer cet amendement
en tout cas de parler et qu'il y a
ensuite un débat sur la trajectoire nous
pouvons l'avoir moi je plaide pour le
maintien des 07 on peut pas donc et là
on vous encore une fois vous allez vous
faire tout ça réduire donc je le dis je
pense qu'il faut maintenant raison
garder il faut se dire que le con vous
avez bientôt fini une période
particulière dans votre famille po et je
conclus monsieur le Président ont
vraiment je vous invite à ne pas voter
cet amendement
oui merci monsieur le Président
j'avoue être très gêné par cette
amendement soutenu par un grand parti
des collègues de la de la majorité mais
je ne suis pas favorable non plus à
cette à cet amendement pour diverses
raisons parce que on peut pas dire le
tout et son contraire en si peu de temps
on peut pas regretter qu'on n'atteint
pas les objectifs en pourcentage et puis
gratter 200 millions qui nous sont
proposés par le par le gouvernement
première chose deuxième chose on peut
pas regretter qu'on fait trop de près et
pas assez de dons les 200 millions ils
vont être pris forcément sur les dons
pire ils vont être pris sur les projets
avec 200 millions en Afrique vous savez
tous mes chers collègues en tout cas
pour ceux qui ont fait des choses sur
cette thématique avec 200 millions en
Afrique on fait des choses absolument
colossales et je comprends la commission
des finances qui veut faire qui cherche
200 millions mais je suivrai par exemple
sur la me
on est sur les immigrés en situation
irrégulière dire là on va faire un
effort j'ai défendu il y a quelques
années un amendement de réduction de 500
millions pour lame là on fait 350
j'aurais soutenu 500 millions trouvons
ces 200 millions ailleurs mes chers
collègues mais là enfin franchement en
conscience je j'ai beaucoup de mal à
voter un amendement comme celui-là et
quand on regarde un peu dans l'avenir il
faudra beaucoup beaucoup plus d'argent
dans l'intérêt de l'Europe dans
l'intérêt de la France par rapport à ce
qui va se passer et en Afrique et c'est
200 millions ils vont être pris sans
doute 80% sur l'Afrique et puis
j'anticipe un tout petit peu sur les
amendements à venir pour pas prendre la
parole monsieur le Président mais quand
on regrette qui est trop de prêt pas
assez de dons et pas assez en même temps
de d'APD je vous rappelle que les prêts
comptent dans le pourcentage de la et
qu'avec 200 millions 200 millions de de
dons vous imaginez ce que ça représente
en prêt puisque sur les prêts on ne on
ne compte évidemment que la bonification
d'intérêt donc moi je recherche une
cohérence dans tout ça je m'en excuse
vraiment auprès des collègues qui
soutiennent cet amendement et pour avoir
beaucoup travaillé sur ces sujets je
peux pas voter quelque chose comme ça
qui me semble contradictoire avec les
objectifs de la France Merci
monsieur le Président Rapin
quelques mots monsieur le Président pour
dire d'abord que je veux pas laisser
dire que cet amendement serait en lien
avec quelques situations politiques
d'aujourd'hui non c'est juste pas
pensable c'est juste pas imaginable il
est signé par je sais pas après de 70
parlementaires ici et donc rien à voir
avec une situation politique telle que
vous pouvez l'envisager surtout quand
elle concerne une seule famille
politique ça c'est le premier point puis
le deuxième point la loi de
programmation août 2021 depuis août 2021
il se sent n'est passé des choses au
plan financier donc on a quand même
quelques soucis à régler on le sait très
bien le gouvernement tant qu'il est là
il refuse un nombre d'amendements
considérable quelquefois qui sont en
hausse de crédit posé sur ses bancs par
quelques que ce soit
membre de sur ces bancs donc non je ne
pouvais pas laisser dire ça et puis de
la situation depuis ou de 2021 elle a
elle a vraiment changé
nous allons poursuivre les explications
d'autres mais je vous signale tout de
suite que je suis saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public sur ces deux amendements
donc merci de vous y préparer Monsieur
Seguin
oui merci monsieur le Président Madame
ministre j'ai bien entendu vos propos et
puis ceux de mon collègue
Rachid themal où il dit un compte un
coup de rabot un coup de rabot de 1,5%
déjà c'est vraiment je sais pas si on
appelle ça un coup de rabot ça c'est le
premier point le second vous dites que
ça en accord avec la loi mais la loi la
loi de Maastricht vous en faites quoi
pendant combien de temps on va pas
respecter les 3% de dettes annuelles et
respecter le montant de la dette qui
doit être plafonné à 60%. on a plus de
crédibilité au sein de l'Europe ou de
moins en moins mais on continue et puis
ça chaque sachant qu'il faut raboter de
200 millions ici on dit ah bah non pas
ici ailleurs mais pas ici et puis on
continue et puis on va continuer combien
de temps parce que je vous rappelle que
chaque fois là on est les bons
samaritains on est heureux de de prêter
au pays étrangers comme disait Alain
juin j'ai envie de tout de suite on est
très fier mais en même temps on le fait
à crédit parce pas de bénéfice si nous
on participe pas avec l'étranger mais
regardez simplement la balance
commerciale on achète tout à l'extérieur
on achète plus rien à l'intérieur on
équilibre plus mais combien de temps ça
va durer alors 200 millions c'est
vraiment un minimum et je pense qu'il
est grand temps de donner le hola donc
je vois très certainement merci Monsieur
sorry
merci monsieur le Président moi
j'interviendrai dans le sens de mon
collègue jeandais pour dire que je ne
comprends pas bien ces deux amendements
en tout cas l'ampleur de ces deux
amendements je ne les comprends pas bien
pour des raisons à la fois de cohérence
et des raisons d'efficacité de notre
politique extérieure de cohérence parce
qu'effectivement nous avons voté à
l'unanimité une voie une loi il y a pas
si longtemps c'était elle a été
promulguée le 4 août 2021 il y avait une
trajectoire dans cette loi que le
gouvernement a infléchi pour en tenant
compte de la situation économique
actuelle donc je ne vois pas pourquoi
nous de notre côté nous allons reprendre
une partie une partie de ces crédits une
partie importante c'est pas un coup de
rabot c'est ça représente à peu près 5%
de l'effort qui a été demandé par par au
niveau du du Sénat et puis en termes
d'efficacité de la politique extérieure
de la France j'ai entendu souvent dire
que la France était 5e en terme d'aide
publique au développement c'est pas tout
à fait exact parce qu'elle est cinquième
des pays de l'OCDE
dans les pays de dans l'OCDE il y a pas
la Russie il y a pas la Chine qui ont
aussi une action extrêmement forte à
l'extérieur donc pour ma part je pense
qu'il est absolument indispensable que
notre pays effectivement dans une
situation qui a changé mais elle a
changé aussi en termes de conflit en
termes de guerre et de difficulté et
donc il me semble absolument important
que notre pays joue son rôle dans ce
domaine là et donc pour ma part je
maintiendrai sur ces amendements merci
monsieur le président Laurent
oui très très rapidement en plus là
comme je suis il se trouve que je suis
d'accord avec le gouvernement pour
maintenir ses crédits ça aurait été
dommage que ça n'arrive pas souvent
d'être d'accord avec le gouvernement
donc il aurait été dommage que je me le
dise pas mais effectivement je pense que
vraiment c'est un amendement qui est
hors de propos par rapport au débat qui
est le nôtre sur ces questions depuis
maintenant un an et depuis l'adoption de
la loi de l'an dernier parce que bon
j'entends des collègues dire aux 200
millions sur le total c'est pas mais par
rapport à la progression de cette année
c'est une proportion très importante
donc cet amendement on fête réduit
considérablement de manière très
significative la progression des crédits
qui sont inscrits au budget de cette
année donc ne dites pas que c'est un
amendement anodin parce que c'est un peu
comme ça qu'il a été argumenté pas du
tout bon de plus le ralentissement de
trajectoire pour finalement décider de
ne pas atteindre les 07 pose quand même
beaucoup de problèmes qu'on a pas
débattu au fond ici mais je pense que ça
méritera un débat plus approfondi puis
dernière chose si des
sénateurs et des groupes cherchent des
économies à faire sur le budget moi j'ai
beaucoup d'autres idées sur le sujet je
pourrais leur donner
monsieur Salman
merci monsieur le Président
effectivement pour répondre à certains
de mes collègues je crois que la
principale dette c'est la dette
climatique et les pays développés en
sont responsables pour une large part et
clairement avec 200 millions d'euros
comme le disait un collègue avec 200
millions d'euros dans les pays en voie
de développement on peut faire des
actions qui sont fantastiques et qui
peuvent les aider effectivement à ne pas
passer par la case fossile et vraiment à
entrer dans une une vraie économie
décarbonée et je pense que c'est surtout
pas dans ces endroits là qu'il faut
dans cette mission qu'il faut raboter
200 millions je trouve ça assez assez
mesquin et complètement déplacé voir
anachronique dans le monde où on est où
on a vraiment un engagement planétaire à
tenir et les pays en voie de
développement ont besoin de cet argent
merci monsieur dodéchini
ce président personnellement je suis
vraiment surpris de cet amendement et du
silence d'ailleurs de certains membres
de la commission des affaires étrangères
de la défense et des forces armées où on
a travaillé largement où on a soutenu
bien sûr les deux rapporteurs pour
terminer ce soir avec un amendement
comme celui-là
moi je pense que mon ami Rachid tamal tu
es mal à la raison c'est un la période
politique que certains vivent qui
conduisent aujourd'hui à cet amendement
c'est un peu c'est un peu décevant parce
que derrière bien sûr ce sont les dons
qui ont les réduits mais derrière ces
dons et ses prêts il y a aussi des
entreprises françaises et donc c'est
tout cela que l'on passe par perte et
profit pour des problèmes internes un
parti politique
allez je conclus par le rapporteur
monsieur Canevet
merci Michel le Président je voudrais
tout d'abord dire rapporteur pour avis
que la loi de la loi de programmation
qui était votée le 4 août 2020 adopté le
4 août 2021 prévoyait des perspectives
budgétaires jusqu'à 2022 mais ne
prévoyez rien au-delà de 2022 donc il
faut savoir être raisonnable je dis à
nos collègues quel est non mais quelle
est la situation réelle de ce budget il
augmente de 10% en ne tenant pas compte
des 200 millions d'euros il augmente de
10% dans le contexte budgétaire que
chacun connaît dans notre pays non mais
il est temps que l'on revienne à la
raison parce que on va pas continuer à
financer l'action publique
on va pas commencer continuer à financer
l'action publique en recourant à la
dette systématiquement pour tout enfin
il y a un moment où on est rattrapé par
la patrouille donc il faudrait
raisonnable nous nous pensons que les
crédits augmentent suffisamment qu'il
faut qu'il puisse être mise en œuvre ce
sont pour l'essentiel des crédits qui
sont en réserve mais pour qu'ils soient
mis en œuvre il faut avoir la capacité
de le faire donc il faut d'abord aussi
que l'ensemble de nos opérateurs sont en
mesure de justifier qu'ils vont pouvoir
mettre en oeuvre les programmes parce
que c'est pas tout de prévoir des
crédits si on n'est pas capable de les
dépenser derrière on ne fera rien et
chers collègues je vous signale que les
07% de
RnB dont on s'est fixé l'objectif c'est
plus 6 milliards d'euros plus 6
milliards d'euros il va falloir les
trouver et chers collègues
très bien bien allez je vous rappelle
que j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public par le groupe les
républicains sur les deux amendements
identiques 4 et 99 la ville de la
commission est par définition favorable
la vie du Gouvernement est défavorable
il va être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixées par l'article
56 du règlement le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votant 343 exprimé 334 pour les
amendements 213 contre 121 et deux
amendements identiques sont adoptés
et je passe au
1259 monsieur le Président Laurent
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est
amendement propose de doubler les
crédits supplémentaires accordés au
compte de bonification afin de réduire
le taux de modification des DTS et ainsi
d'augmenter la possibilité d'accès au
DTS des pays les plus pauvres
aujourd'hui chaque membre du FMI soit
attribut une cote par deux DTS en
fonction de sa position relative dans
l'économie mondiale mais les modes de
calcul actuels des quote-part qui est
une moyenne pondérée en fonction du PIB
à 50% du degré d'ouverture de l'économie
à 30% des variations économiques à 15%
et des réserves officiels de change à
5%, ce mode de calcul désavantage les
pays pauvres dont l'accès au quote-part
de DTS alors que ce sont eux qui en ont
le plus besoin ils pourraient il serait
en effet souhaitable que les pays
pauvres soient prioritaires dans l'accès
à ces financements dans la situation
actuelle d'autant qu'ils sont les plus
impactés par tous les chocs économiques
climatiques et autres donc pour toutes
ces raisons nous proposons de doubler
les crédits supplémentaires à accorder
au compte de bonification ce qui permet
de réduire le taux de bonification des
DTS nous doublons notre prêt de droit de
tirage spéciaux de la Banque de France
afin qu'il atteigne 6 milliards d'euros
pour cela il faut alimenter ce compte de
bonification pour réduire le taux
d'intérêt du DTS aujourd'hui de 1,5
points pour pouvoir faire des prêts à
taux zéro il faut compenser ce montant
d'où le compte de bonification c'est la
technique proposée dans l'amendement
c'est tout à fait possible et d'ailleurs
nous avions écouté en commission le
directeur général du Trésor nous
expliquer cette mécanique et c'est on
l'écoutant que nous avons abouti à cette
proposition qui rend possible
d'Aug ainsi la part d'accès aux DTS des
pays les plus qui en ont le plus besoin
merci
avis de la commission
c'est le président de chaque collègue
c'est un héros technique en allant
technique notamment propose d'augmenter
de 260 millions d'euros les crédits
destinés à bonification des prêts
accordés par la Banque de France sous
forme de droit de tirage spéciaux qui
l’unité de compte international utilisé
par le FMI notre compréhension que les
auteurs visent les crédits destinés à la
bonification des prêts accordés par la
Banque de France dans le cas du fond
pour la réduction de la pauvreté de la
croissance le FRPC du FMI doté de 130
millions d'euros en 2023 l'objectif des
auteurs de l'avendement et d'augmenter
le montant de l'encours de prêt à taux
zéro accordé par la Banque de France et
qui dispose de la garantie de l'État
avec les dispositions de la loi de
finance pour 2022 en premier lieu il
nous apparaît que montant de l'encours
de préconceptionnelle accordée par la
Banque de France dans le cas du FRPC
réside d'une part la trajectoire de
participation de la France à
l'augmentation des moyens du fort
d'autre part du montant de la garantie
accordé par l'État alors le président
abandonné
pas le montant de la garantie accordée
par les pas et par suite il ne semble
pas qu'il permet de réaliser l'objectif
des auteurs à ce grand lieu nous
souhaiterions indiquer que nous sommes
défavorables à cette hausse de cette
ampleur des crédits de la mission en
considérant que l'intention du gouverne
des auteurs et bien que le gouvernement
lève le gaz à part et moi nous on
adopter un amendement de l'objet et de
le dire 200 millions d'euros les fruits
cris de la mission enfin l'observons que
l'avènement ne vise pas la bonne action
du programme 110 puisqu'il propose
d'aborder les crédits de la coopération
financière bilatérale alors que le FRPC
est financé au titre de la coopération
financière multilatérale et donc un avis
défavorable merci il y avait du
gouvernement madame la ministre
les gouvernement n'est pas favorable à
cet amendement la France est pleinement
engagée dans les mouvements des
réallocations de DTS au pays les plus
pauvres comme vous savez le président de
la République avaient lancé cette idée
au sommet sur les financements des
économies africaines en 2021 au-delà de
l'objectif des 20% fixé en juin la
France engagée a réalisé jusqu'à 30% de
ces BTS dans les cadres des budgets 2022
2023 la France contribue à hauteur des 5
milliards d'euros qui correspondent à
notre engagement de 20% et nous sommes
en discussion avec les FMI pour voir
comment monter à 30%. les besoins des
bonifications qui accompagnent cette
réallocation nous sommes bien pris en
compte dans les crédits du programme
samedi avec 40 millions pour les fonds
pour la réduction de la pauvreté 80 pour
le fond pour la résilience ces montants
sont jugés
en total contradiction avec la priorité
qui nous souhaitons tous accorder à
notre action sous forme de don c'est
donc un avis défavorable du gouvernement
merci je vais mettre le 1259 avec deux
avis défavorables qui pour
qui contre
acheter deux amendements en discussion
commune le 1221
retirez le
1258 monsieur le Président Laurent
c'est amendement visa équilibrer les
politiques de près et de dons au sein de
la
c'est le budget prévoit une augmentation
plus conséquente des crédits du
programme 110 que du programme 209 et
nous nous proposons de transférer 46,5
millions d'euros vers le programme de
109 ce qui permettrait une augmentation
similaire entre les deux programmes et
ce qui permettrait de concentré
davantage de moyens et d'accentuer la
trajectoire vers l'augmentation des dons
qui ont le sait vont prioritairement
vers les pays les plus pauvres ceux qui
en ont le plus besoin pour les
populations les plus vulnérables et dans
les secteurs sociaux qui sont la base du
développement la France est un des pays
qui investit le moins son aide dans les
services sociaux de base et je crois que
nous pouvons améliorer ça
seul un quart de notre APD bénéficie au
PMA au pays les moins avancés et seul
14% de notre aide est à louer au 19 pays
prioritaires de les Françaises alors
qu'ils font tous partie de la catégorie
le PMA donc on doit accélérer le
mouvement engagé pour aller vers une
politique de dons supplémentaires et
c'est le sens de notre amendement merci
avis de la commission sur rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président
comment dire l'amendement du président
Laurent va dans le sens inverse du de
l'amendement qui a été adopté tout à
l'heure par l'Assemblée je rappelle que
depuis 2018 les dons Z projet ont
augmenté de 60% quant à l'intervention
par prêt a augmenté de 40%, ça veut dire
qu'effectivement il y a un rééquilibrage
vers les dons en net projet et donc peut
considérer que c'est déjà satisfait la
demande du président Laurent merci il y
avait du gouvernement madame la ministre
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs le Gouvernement
est défavorable à cet amendement car il
n'est pas nécessaire conformément la loi
de programmation 2021 car il s'agit bien
d'une loi la part des dons dans la
française doit représenter au moins 70%
de du montant total de notre aide nous
en sommes aujourd'hui à 78% ou du moins
nous en étions en 78% avant l'adoption
des amendements réduisant de 200
millions la le programme 209 et
uniquement le programme 209
merci je mets je vois le 1258 avec deux
avis défavorables qui est pour
qui contre
je vais mettre voix l'ensemble des
crédits de la mission de public au
développement j'ai été saisi d'une
demande de scrutin public
je vous rappelle que la commission des
finances est favorable l'adoption des
crédits de cette mission
de scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin éclos
votant 342 exprimés 261 pour 246 contre
0 le budget
et de l'aide publique au développement
est adopté après
à l'étage j'ai un amendement 1222
monsieur temal
alors là il y a pas d'argent en plus ou
moins donc je vais starter de rassurer
la partie droite de l'hémicycle plus
sérieusement il s'agit simplement
d'améliorer on va dire le pilotage les
de les plus complètement avec notamment
en indiquant en créant deux indicateurs
d'une part la part des prêts et des dons
dans l'aide bilatérale et multi français
c'est attendu je crois pour mieux
piloter et d'autre part les prêts les
dons affectés au prioritaires je
rappelle les 19 pays je crois que c'est
important donc voilà c'est un souci
d'efficacité et de meilleures pilotage
sur le rapporteur
qui est le président mais chaque
collègue c'est la lendemain qui a pour
objectif de performance nouveau qui
permettrait de identifier la part de la
République développement consacré auprès
ou aux hommes la disposition renforce
l'information du Parlement dans la vie
favorable
avis du gouvernement
les gouvernements défavorables de
réduction de indicateurs de performance
pour la mission APD pour des raisons des
technicités liées à la mesure de la
les objectifs et les indicateurs de
performance qui évaluent l'efficacité de
la mission APD ont déjà été profondément
révisés pour tenir compte de nouvelles
orientations difficiles de février 2018
il est vrai que aucun indicateur ne
permet actuellement de rendre compte de
la part des prêts des donnes à louer au
19 pays prioritaires et pour notre aide
bilatérale multilatérale de manière
générale cela s'explique par des
difficultés inhérentes à la mesure de la
PDM je rappelle que la pédéine mesure
statistique très différente de notre
fort budgétaire il n'existe pas des
liens facile à établir entre notre APD
déclaré à posteriori et les budgets que
vous votez a priori les ministère
initiés depuis 2018 une traçabilité de
son APD par programme budgétaire mais ce
n'est pas le cas de l'Agence française
de développement pour laquelle c'est
plus difficile puisque l'intervienne
aussi en prêt donc comme je dis au début
le gouvernement défavorable je vous
remercie
très bien je me vois le 1222 avec un
avis favorable de la commission des
favorable du gouvernement qui est pour
qui contre
il est adopté
nous avons ensuite le 1268 du
gouvernement madame la ministre
merci Monsieur prudent mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs perd cet
amendement le gouvernement propose de
clarifier l'organisation de la
commission d'évaluation de l'aide
publique au développement en explicitant
donc en écrivant explicitement qu'elle
sera présidée par le Premier Président
de la Cour des comptes et il précise
également cet amendement le rôle
d'information du Parlement
et avis de la commission sur le
rapporteur il est défavorable monsieur
le Président d'abord parce que la
commission des finances regrette que la
commission d'évaluation n'est pas encore
été mise en oeuvre en place et ne
fonctionne pas encore autant le
gouvernement a fait diligence sur un
grand nombre de dispositions qui
figurait dans la loi du 4 août 2021 des
rapports etc pour l'information du
Parlement et nous en sommes
particulièrement satisfait mesdames les
ministres mais pour ce qui concerne ceci
cela ne nous paraît pas opportun d'abord
parce que il ne nous paraît pas
souhaitable que le premier président de
la cour des
celui à qui on adresse les déclarations
d'intérêts soient aussi celui qui va
présider la commission je crois qu'il
faut qu'il y ait une répartition des
choses et l'ensemble de ces éléments
nous conduit à dire en commission des
finances que cela n'est pas au portable
deux prises de parole d'abord le
président gonta plus le président
merci Monsieur le monsieur le Président
oui juste je voulais prendre la parole
parce que nous allons voter contre cet
amendement et je voulais souligner quand
même son caractère et quelque peu
cavaliers si le premier objectif ne pose
pas de problème le second nous interroge
et en premier chef on peut se poser la
question pourquoi le gouvernement veut
voter au détour d'une fin de PLF une
modification de la loi de programmation
relatif au développement solidaire et la
lutte contre les unités les uniques
inégalités pardon mondiale vous voulez
ça a été rappelé changer la présidence
de la commission indépendante chargée
d'évaluer l'efficacité la destination de
l'aide publique française pour la placer
sous la lettre du premier président de
la Cour des comptes vous invoquez la
difficulté au regard de la composition
de cette commission de choisir un
président
mais cette commission n'est même pas
composée n'a jamais été réuni plus d'un
an après le vote de la loi il est donc
hors de question de modifier l'intention
du législateur sans même l'avoir
éprouvée et puis je profite aussi de ce
temps puisque vous mettez sujet en débat
quand est-ce que cette commission
justement indépendante sera réunie pour
la première fois sa mise en œuvre nous
permettrait d'éviter les financements
problématiques dont je parlais tout à
l'heure comme kawsi béga
aurons-nous comme prévu par la loi un
débat parlementaire sur le rapport du
gouvernement sur la politique de
solidarité internationale publiée en
juin quand sera publié le rapport
portant sur l'utilisation de la taxe sur
les transactions financières quand sera
opérationnel le ciblage qualitatif
permettant un déploiement jeanré de
notre aide publique donc madame la
ministre avant de modifier la loi de
programmation relative au développement
solidaire à la lutte contre les
inégalités mondiale peut-être
faudrait-il commencer par l'appliquer
merci monsieur le président
deux observations l'une sur la forme et
l'autre sur le fond sur la forme il est
évident que la manière dont le
gouvernement a procédé avec du reste
beaucoup de Gênes et tout à fait
critiquable puisque moi-même je n'ai été
avisé qu'il y a 48 heures de ce projet
d'amendement et donc j'en ai
immédiatement référé un certain nombre
de présidents de groupe que je pouvais
joindre sur le fond ce qui est vrai
c'est que lorsque nous avons négocié
en CMP la loi d'orientation
sur les deux développements c'était la
position du Sénat de confier la
présidence au président de la Cour des
comptes puisque je rappelle que c'est
lui qui héberge
cette commission donc il ne nous
semblait pas contraire au fonctionnement
de cette future Commission le fait de
lui confier la présidence sachant que le
choix c'est entre le président de la
présidente de la Cour des comptes ou un
expert dont personne ne connaît le nom
puisque de toute façon ces experts ne
sont même pas nommés pour l'instant donc
moi j'ai en utilisant les arguments de
mon collègue Gontard on peut aussi tenir
le raisonnement inverse car il est vrai
que cette commission ne s'est jamais
réunie nous ne cessons de dire je l'ai
dit au ministre
respectifs et c'est un c'est une vraie
difficulté car c'est une loi sur
laquelle nous avons beaucoup travaillé
qui est censé améliorer le dispositif
d'aide au développement et qui nécessite
absolument que le Parlement soit
consulté par l'utilisation des dépenses
considérables que nous allons
vraisemblablement que cette assemblée va
voter dans quelques instants donc notre
appréciation était plutôt constructive
et qui consistait à dire si franchement
le fait de confier au président de la
Cour des comptes cette commission si ça
avait pour effet de faire fonctionner la
commission nous accepterions cette
proposition je voudrais simplement être
sûr et c'est le gouvernement que
j'interroge pour sur le fait de savoir
si véritablement vous avez l'intention
de mettre en place cette commission qui
est absolument nécessaire et qui a été
voulu par le législateur en CMP merci
Monsieur themal
merci Monsieur président effectivement
quand on revient à la genèse de cette
commission d'évaluation faut se rappeler
le pourquoi il y avait une question
également de qui de la politique de
l'être les plus honnêtement d'abord son
portage politique et son contrôle
politique que j'ai envie de dire et puis
est arrivé dans les débats cette idée de
commission de relations pourquoi pas
après beaucoup de datament nous avons eu
un accord et l'accord on l'avait dit à
l'époque effectivement dans l'hémicycle
mais aussi en commission mix par la
terre qu'à partir du moment où on
accrochait cette structure à la Cour des
comptes alors il fallait pas être grand
clair pour comprendre la suite de
l'opération qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
d'accord et c'est vrai que on va dire un
ancien député de la majorité
présidentielle avait beaucoup vrai pour
que ça n'avance pas force cette
constater que maintenant depuis
maintenant un an et demi il n'y a pas
cette commission donc on peut tous se
regarder c'est de l'oeuf la poule et on
attend et on peut continuer d'attendre
donc là il faut être à peu près sérieux
d'ailleurs je le dis au rapporteur je
peux pas dire d'un côté il y a une loi
il faut la respecter et juste qui vont
nous dire que il y a une loi mais on
peut retirer quand même de l'argent je
crois qu'à un moment donné il faut aussi
choisir ses arguments donc moi je suis
cohérent avec moi-même j'étais cohérent
sur la partie budgétaire je vais l'être
sur la partie également qui celle qui
est proposée en disant globalement vous
n'avez pas effectivement convoqué cette
réunion j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure la
question de suicide donc je pourrais
faire d'autres griefs mais maintenant
nous sommes là la question c'est comment
nous avions donc je pense
qu'effectivement il faut maintenant
avancer il faut pouvoir faire en sorte
que c'est amendement soit adopté avec
peut-être un sous amendement si vous
êtes d'accord madame la ministre
notamment le deuxième point je pense
qu'il faut d'abord parler que la
communication se fait vis-à-vis du
Parlement sur les finances en public
mobilisés et après seulement le public
je crois inverser je pense que c'est
mieux quand même c'est une commission
qui parle au parlementaire je crois que
c'est mieux voilà je le dis maintenant
il faut avancer il faut être après
sérieux et cohérent et j'en appelle
effectivement adopté cet amendement même
si sur la forme on peut avoir beaucoup
choisir mais là il faut avancer merci
monsieur le rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président alors moi je
crois qu'effectivement c'est pas très
bon d'abord outre le risque
constitutionnel comme je l'ai évoqué
tout à l'heure il y a aussi le fait que
le premier président de la Cour des
comptes préside par définition la Cour
des comptes et que la Cour des Comptes
est appelée aussi à procéder à des
évaluations des politiques publiques
liées au développement notamment et si
nous avons voulu une commission dite
indépendante c'est bien pour qu'elle
soit effectivement indépendante et si
elle est totalement dépendante de du
désirata du président de la Cour des
comptes du premier président de la Cour
des comptes je pense que
on n'ira pas au bout de l'objectif que
l'on s'était fixé au moment où nous
avons voté la loi du 4 août 2021 donc
moi je vous appelle chers collègues a
bien réfléchi sur ce vote
bien
allez je mets aux voix l'amendement 1268
du gouvernement avec un avis défavorable
de la commission qui est pour
je vais bien la main parce que
baisser la main qui est contre
il est adopté
après l'article 41 des le 1224 monsieur
temal
I
merci monsieur le Président bon c'est
amendement tout simplement
propose au gouvernement de remettre un
rapport annuel au Parlement sur les
actions de développement en faveur de la
Constitution d'état civil fiable je vais
pas reprendre l'argumentation je l'ai
développé tout à l'heure dans leur
demande intervention mais nous pensons
nous que la loi du 4 août 2021 aurait dû
être l'occasion de placer l'objectif de
l'enregistrement des décences et de la
mise en place d'état civil fiable au
rang des priorités de la politique de
développement de la France je vais pas
reprendre non plus le rapport de
l'Unicef de 2019 j'ai cité tout à
l'heure simplement en Asie du Sud et
l'Afrique subsaharienne concentre 87%
des enfants de moins de 5 ans non
enregistré nous savons tous que il y a
là des conséquences dramatiques pour ses
enfants qui viendront des adultes
invisibles sans enregistrement l'état
civil il n'y a pas ou peu d'accès à
l'éducation à la santé aux droits
sociaux au droit électoraux c'est donc
commandement devrait être l'occasion de
permettre le gouvernement de rendre
compte des actions de la France en
faveur de la promotion de la situation
d'état civil fiable et l'enregistrement
des décences et le délivrance d'acte de
naissance merci avis de la commission
c'est le président de la pétanque du
Sénat pour les rapports c'est la vie
défavorable si avis du gouvernement
se présente et messieurs les sénateurs
le Gouvernement est défavorable cet
amendement car il existe déjà des
mécanismes d'évaluation et donc nous
vous avons donné satisfaction avant
l'heure je rappelle que la France adopté
en juin 2021 une feuille de route pour
renforcer son action internationale en
matière d'état civil avec trois
objectifs accroître la mobilisation
internationale en faveur de l'état civil
renforcer cette prise en compte dans
l'aide publique au développement et
enfin obtenir une meilleure
communication sur les enjeux en la
matière ces trois indicateurs font
l'objet tous les deux ans d'un rapport
le premier de ces rapport doit être
publiée d'ici le mois de juin 2023
je voudrais le soutenir je vais vous
dire pourquoi
en Afrique de l'Ouest on est on a
beaucoup travaillé avec le président
Richard qui préside ce groupe et aussi
dans d'autres parties du monde on a des
millions d'enfants fantômes alors c'est
des problèmes pour le développement mais
c'est aussi des problèmes pour notre
sécurité parce que ces gens vont voyager
ils n'ont pas d'identité fiable ils vont
arriver en Europe ou ailleurs et on a
aussi des problèmes de sécurité des
actes d'état civil et on a aussi des
problèmes avec des gens qui fraudent
l'état civil en France les problèmes
sont liés les problèmes d'état civil
dans les pays concernés on avait même
demandé l'année dernière une liste des
pays non fiables pour ce qui concerne
les pièces d'identité ne serait-ce que
pour nos services des migrations en
France on va s'adresser pour des
certificats ou des validités de
certificat de naissance à des entités
qui ne sont absolument pas fiables alors
peut-être qu'il y aura un rapport dans
six mois mais je pense que voter la
demande de nos collègues aujourd'hui
c'est juste un signe on en fait pas
assez il faut absolument travailler sur
ce sujet c'est un problème essentiel
pour le développement mais c'est un
problème aussi essentiel en matière de
sécurité et de fraude documentaire si je
mets aux voix le 1224 avec deux avis
négatifs qui pour
qui est contre
ne pas adopter
nous allons procéder au vote des crédits
du compte spécial prêt à des États
étrangers figurant l'état des je vous
rappelle que la commission des finances
est favorable à l'adoption des crédits
du compte spécial qui est pour
qui contre
et bien les crédits du compte spécial
sont adoptés je vais suspendre la séance
elle sera reprise à 21h30 pour l'examen
des articles de la seconde partie non
rattachée au crédit la séance est
suspendue
[Musique]